se você já comprou alguma fruta legume
ou verdura e depois encontro eles
chateado na gaveta da sua geladeira e
ficou mal de jogar Comida fora já tentou
plantar algum tempero e não sabia nem
por onde começar já sentiu que você sabe
pouco sobre a sua alimentação mesmo com
tanta informação disponível na internet
eu acho que todos nós já passamos por
isso eu por exemplo eu já matei tanto pé
de manjericão que eu tenho até medo
deles irem puxar meu pé à noite como
todas essas derrotas cotidianas que eu
já tive na horta e na cozinha hoje eu
luto por um mundo onde todo mundo possa
até acesso à informação sobre o que a
gente come porque são informações
simples mas que são muito
revolucionários pódio da corrida que a
gente tem hoje a gente diz conector de
alimentação a gente precisa voltar assim
entender a gente precisa voltar entender
o que a comida como
e os nossos pratos eles contam uma
história você tá conseguindo ao ouvir a
história que o seu prato conta eu não
conseguia eu não tinha ideia do impacto
do que eu comia de como isso interferia
na minha saúde Eu também não refletia
sobre como que eu pensasse de onde vem o
meu alimento onde ele foi produzido como
ele foi produzido por quem como que
aquilo podia interferir no meio ambiente
isso para mim foi tudo muito novo eu era
muito perdida muito insegura em relação
ao alimento e aí eu fui procurar uma
nutricionista porque eu já tava sentindo
os impactos da má alimentação na minha
saúde quando eu cheguei no consultório
eu comecei eu sou bióloga de formação e
eu comecei a cruzar as informações
nutricionais que eu recebia com toda a
minha visão de mundo a forma como eu
enxergava os hábitos que eu queria
adquirir dali para frente foi difícil
achar uma profissional que acreditasse
que a comida para mim ela não era só
nutriente
e era só nutrientes do meu corpo eu
queria entender todo o impacto Social e
Ambiental que o alimentos passava até
ele chegar na minha mesa eu passei a
refletir sobre todas as embalagens que
envolveu o meu alimento passei a
observar que eu queria começar a comprar
o meu alimento direto do Produtor Eu
queria um mundo onde a economia fosse
mais justa por que que eu tô trazendo
esse ponto econômico porque hoje
quarenta por cento da população
brasileira passa fome tá em segurança
alimentar quarenta por cento da
população está no campo quem também está
no campo são os agricultores familiares
que produzem setenta por cento dos
alimentos que a gente consome esse mesmo
agricultor produz a nossa comida mas não
ganha o suficiente para comprar a comida
dele conforme eu fui ganhando mais
consciência sobre o que eu comia veio
junto mais responsabilidade como que eu
podia ajudar a democratizar o acesso à
alimentação democratizar o acesso à
informação que as pessoas entenderem o
nosso sistema
bom e foi aí que começou a história que
me trouxe até aqui hoje o meu trabalho é
encantar as pessoas e despertar elas
para uma jornada individual que faz com
que elas consigam comer de uma forma
cada vez mais sustentável mas como usar
o nosso prato como uma ferramenta de
resolução como aproximar isso para o dia
a dia das pessoas a forma que eu escolhi
para fazer isso foi espalhar hortas
agroecológicas por toda a cidade A ideia
é usar as hortas como uma ferramenta de
transformação como um espaço de
encantamento o quê que pode ser mais
prazeroso do que consumiu uma salada que
você acabou de plantar de fazer uma
batata no forno e colocar um Alecrim que
você pegou da sua própria horta e não
pensem vocês que eu comecei a minha
horta no espaço amplo e iluminado a
gente fantasia quem traz enormes não
gente eu nem varanda tenho eu comecei a
minha horta no caixote de feira no meu
bom então eu precisei tirar um sofá para
ela conseguir ficar no único espaço que
batia sol e o pior esse caixote de feira
morreu eu deixei a minha primeira horta
morrer e isso foi super importante para
que eu começasse a buscar conhecimento a
buscar informação sobre isso hoje aquele
caixote de feira se tornaram esses vasos
que vocês estão vendo aqui que ficam em
cima de um móvel com rodinha porque o
móvel com rodinha porque quando a gente
começa a plantar a gente volta na nossa
aula lá da 4ª série onde a gente entende
que o sol se movimenta ao longo do dia
EA cada estação do ano então para horta
pegar as quatro horas de sol que ela
precisa pegar todos os dias a maioria
das espécies eu acaba precisando mudar
ela de lugar esse tipo de informação a
gente só tem quando a gente começa a
plantar a beleza de plantar é que é
muito democrático todo mundo pode
plantar
e não importa espaço que você tenha o
Qual informação prévia que você tenha a
horta é para todos a horta é um espaço
de inspiração ela é um espaço que te
convida você só precisa tá aberto para
essa experiência aorta e simula que você
desenvolva uma relação afetiva com a
comida nela você passa do cultivo para
nutrição e até a compostagem você passa
até amigas minhocas que vão transformar
todos eu resido em adubo E aí você vai
agarrar um amor nessas minhocas não é
difícil amarelas porque a cada minhoca
tem de 2 a 15 corações como não gostar
de um bichinho desse a minha aposta é
que se envolvendo esse processo faz com
que você coma mais vegetais porque você
quer e não porque alguém falou que você
precisa comer mais fruta mais legal meu
mais verdura quando a gente se envolve
com o plantio a gente aprende como a
planta nasce como ela cresce a gente
aprende que uma são mais difíceis do que
outras E aí a gente vai escolher Plan
a galinha e não manjericão a gente vai
descobrir que várias espécies são
comestíveis e a gente nem sabia e a
gente vai aprender a esperar quando a
gente aprende a esperar o ponto certo de
escolher a gente muda a nossa relação
com a alimentação Qual é a possibilidade
de você deixar uma abobrinha estragar na
gaveta da geladeira quando você esperou
tanto tempo para poder colher ela
plantar também estimula a gente a
cozinhar o que que é mais especial do
que tá cozinhando e falar eu vou ali
pegar um tempinho na minha horta e essa
sensação é igualmente prazerosa se a sua
horta tiver amarrada na sua janela
quando a gente começa a plantar não
significa que a gente vai plantar tudo
que a gente come Mas significa que a
gente vai começar a refletir sobre tudo
que a gente se compra e o meu papel o
nosso papel é fazer essa transformação
de consciência acontecer é se envolvendo
o ciclo do plantio passar valorizar quem
planta a nossa comida e entender toda a
complexidade que
o nosso sistema alimentar se você não
sabe por onde começar começa pelo que tá
o seu alcance se o desperdício isso é
uma coisa que te incomoda por exemplo
começa a pequeno Escolhe um vasinho hoje
tem inteiro para plantar para que quando
você for usar você consuma só o que você
precisa e não deixe o resto do mas
estragar na geladeira você também pode e
na feira mais perto da sua casa como
Novo Olhar começar entendeu que tá na
época comer uma fruta mais doce e ainda
economizar Enquanto você tiver na feira
você pode inclusive comprar uma cenoura
com rama uma beterraba com folha e aí se
arriscar na sua primeira farofa de talos
se você não usar os vegetais todos de
uma vez você pode começar você vai
entregar até na conservação deles o
quanto que é a nossa vida muda ia se a
gente soubesse desde sempre que a gente
conservar a cenoura ou beterraba em
potes cheios de água elas não estragam
se a gente soubesse disso a gente
eu não teria ajudado a contribuir para o
dado de que um terço de toda a comida no
mundo é desperdiçado e essa dica Vale
também para tudo que nasce embaixo da
terra a mandioquinha o rabanete a
cúrcuma o gengibre o passo a passo pra
comer melhor vai depender de qual porta
de entrada você usar você pode começar
plantando orégano comprando uma cesta de
orgânico cozinhando sua própria comida
com postando não importa o importante é
se apaixonar pelo processo é consolidada
a primeira mudança e nesse caminho
encantar todo mundo que estiver à sua
volta a partir das pequenas escolhas
individuais a gente vai se unindo em um
movimento muito maior que vai dos
simples que eu mais avançado do
individual para o coletivo só precisa
começar por um primeiro passo qual vai
ser o seu obrigada
[Aplausos]
E aí